lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
adquirir práctica en la escritura de
series en notación sigma y tengo una
serie aquí arriba tenemos 7 más 9 +11 y
continuamos sumando hasta 405 así que en
primer lugar tenemos que pensar en lo
que está pasando aquí cómo podemos
pensar en lo que le está pasando a cada
término sucesivo aquí tenemos un 7 y
luego continuamos con el 9 y luego vamos
al 11 y parece que estamos sumando 2
cada vez parece que esta es una serie
aritmética así que sumamos dos y luego
sumamos dos otra vez y vamos a continuar
sumando dos cada vez hasta que lleguemos
a 405 entonces vamos a pensar en cuántas
veces estamos sumando dos para llegar a
405 405 es 7 más 2 por cuanto dejen de
escribir esto tenemos 405
es igual a 7 más 2 por equis
solo estoy tratando de descubrir cuántas
veces le tengo que sumar 2 al 7 para
llegar a 405 y esto es igual a si
restamos 7 de los dos lados tenemos 398
es igual a 2x y dividimos los dos lados
entre 2
y esto es igual a 199 es igual a equis
entonces esencialmente vamos a sumar 2
199 veces esta es la primera vez que
sumas dos esta es la segunda sumamos dos
una vez sumamos dos dos veces y aquí
estamos sumando 2 199 veces a nuestro 7
original así que vamos a pensar en esto
un poco más esta es una suma y hay un
par de formas en que podemos pensar en
esto
cuántas veces estamos sumando dos así
que empezamos sumando 20 veces en el
número 7 no hemos sumado ningún 2 y
debemos sumar 2 199 veces pensemos en
esto un poco más esto va a ser igual a 7
más 2 que cuando k es igual a 0
esto va a ser igual a 7 cuando k sea
igual a 1 será 7 más 2 por 1 es igual a
9 cuando acá sea igualados esto va a ser
7 más 2 por 2 que es igual a 11 y así
continuamos y cuando acá es igual a 199
va a ser igual a 7 + 2 por 199 es igual
a 398 y esto es igual a 405 así que esta
es una forma en la que podemos
escribirlo y hay otra forma en la que
podemos escribir esto lo voy a hacer con
un color diferente si queremos iniciar
con nuestro índice acá igual a 1
entonces vamos a ver el primer término
va a ser 72 por k menos 1 no tenga el
primer término funciona porque en
realidad no estamos sumando 21 menos 1
es igual a 0 así que esto va a ser igual
a 7
luego cuando acá es igual a 2 vamos a
sumar 2 una vez porque 2 menos uno es
igual a 1 por 2 es 2 y el resultado es
este y continuamos así cuantos términos
en total vamos a tener aquí bueno una
manera de pensarlo es aumentar los
índices en 1 así que vamos a ir de acá
igual a 1 hasta 200 y puedes verificar
esto cuando k es igual a 200 esto va a
ser igual a 200 menos uno que es 199 por
2 es 398 7 es igual a 405 así que cuando
k es igual a 200
aquí tenemos nuestro último término
entonces estas dos son formas legítimas
de expresar estas series aritméticas
usando la notación sigma